-Congratulations on winning.
-Thank you.
-This is the trophy right here.
Do you mind if I bring it up?
-That's good.
-Wow! It's actually
really heavy.
Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah.
-Yeah, just set it right there.
-That's really heavy.
-Yeah.
-Wow. What a great trophy.
What are you
going to do with this?
-Probably hang
it up somewhere or,
like, put it on, like,
one of my desks.
-You can't hang this thing.
It's 100 pounds.
-Yeah, yeah, I can't hang --
-You have to lean it against --
It's so heavy.
You got to build
a whole new room around it.
I want to put
this over here just for now
so I can see your face,
because it's giant.
Explain this to me.
How does it work?
What goes into it?
Because I think people think,
"Oh, you just play
video games and you won."
It's like, no,
I think there's --
You put a lot of work into this.
-Yeah.
-Am I right?
-So, like,
long practice every day.
Like, every day, I wake up,
got to, like,
warm up my hands for 30 minutes.
Then I got to pretty much,
like, you know, play --
warm up my hands
by playing, like,
"Fortnite Creative,"
stuff like that.
-So, wait.
Walk me through your day.
So, what time do you wake up?
-We talking school day
or a weekend?
-Let's talk weekend.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Maybe like 12:00, 1:00.
-Oh, man.
I want to be you so bad, dude.
I'm really -- I'm so jealous.
I'm so jealous of you right now.
So, you wake up
at 12:00 noon, yeah?
And before you warm up
your hands, what do you do?
Yeah. What do you eat?
What do you eat at 12:00 noon?
-Maybe a banana.
-Okay. Gotcha.
All right, I like bananas.
-Yeah.
-So, you get a --
But then you get on to the game
and you start playing
immediately or no?
-Yeah, I, like, get on,
warm up with that,
and then I go into,
like, a call,
talk to, like,
my friends, and all that,
go over strategies and then --
-Do you play just strangers or
do you play with, like, a --
-No, like, a team, like, friends
and stuff like that, yeah.
-You're on a team now.
-Mm-hmm.
-What is the name of your team?
-Sentinels.
-Sentinels. Yeah, so,
you get on with those guys
and you --
It's Monday through --
It's every day or what is it?
-Pretty much, yeah.
It's like my job.
-That's -- Wow.
And did your parents --
I know they're proud of you,
but, at first,
were they like...
I mean, yeah.
But, at first,
they got to be like,
"Hey, we got to talk, Bugha."
You know, yeah, let's --"
What is Bugha from?
-My grandpa gave me the name
when I was, like, a baby.
He used to say like,
"Bugha, Bugha, Bugha,"
and I used to laugh.
-Oh, no way.
-So that's where I get it from.
-Hey, good for that.
I love grandpa stories.
So, your parents
go, "Okay, this is fun,
but you got to get
working over at, like,
7-Eleven or something.
You got to get a job."
-Yeah, so, like, pretty much,
when they found out, like,
I could actually do this for
pretty much a job, like,
was when I pretty much got
signed to the team and all that.
But before that, I just did,
like, little competitions
and made, like,
a little bit of money off that.
-Like, how much money did you
win the first competition?
-$100.
-Yeah, nothing.
[ Laughs ]
-What are you? 16? $100?
You must have
freaked out and said,
"Mom, dad, this is something.
I can make money.
And they're like,
"It's only $100, buddy."
But that's a lot of money.
-To me, it was at the time,
because, like --
-To me, it is now.
Yeah, I mean...
Wow, $100?
So you win 100 bucks and then
you go, "I can do this."
And then this happens.
I mean, did you freak out?
-I don't know.
It's like I had, like,
no emotion,
but, at the same time,
it felt, like, unreal.
I don't know.
-Because you were just -- You
were just in the zone?
-Yeah, pretty much.
-So, what time of day was
this that you won?
-When it happened?
-Yeah.
-Like midday yesterday.
-Like when you wake up?
12:00 noon?
Yeah. Woke up, had a banana,
won $3 million.
No big deal. Not bad.
So, I just -- I've got to
congratulate you on this.
This is great.
This is a great trophy.
And I hope to
see you again, buddy.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-Good job.
-Appreciate it.
-Kyle "Bugha" Giersdorf.